hey you guys doing another flickers of
fear going back to the 1970s and talking
about a movie that
man i just feel like is really really
underrated and really really underseen i
don't know why it's not better known i
don't know
i mean it really should be up there with
like some of the best horror of the 70s
particularly psychological horror which
is what this is this is magic from 1978
and i know that a couple of you have
seen it because i know that i've gotten
a couple of recommendations to do this
and i've actually been wanting to do
this for a really long time because i've
seen this multiple times
this is one of those movies i think i
feel like it was on basic cable a lot
like back in the early 80s and i feel
like because i probably saw it like in
pieces like a bunch of the time and uh
you know anything that's about like a
creepy
dummy like a ventriloquist dummy is
gonna like get my attention
and so the the crazy thing about this
movie though is that
even though it's about a scary
ventriloquist dummy and in that sense it
is a horror movie but
i saw this other review of it so this is
like the classiest killer doll movie
like you'll ever see because it's like
so many
uh oscar winners behind this it's just
like the the pool of talent like in this
movie is just like [ __ ] amazing right
so it's like anthony hopkins uh plays
the main character and margaret is also
in this burgess meredith is in this so
you know it's just the acting is great
it's directed by richard attenborough
who i think most people nowadays
probably know is like more of an actor
like because he was in jurassic park and
stuff like that but he was also a
director and he directed some great
[ __ ] movies he did uh shadow lands
about c.s lewis which is a great movie
he did chaplin
gandhi a chorus line so you know he has
a bunch of oscars i think maybe two
maybe more than that um and it was based
on a book uh by william goldman who also
adapted the screenplay which was
something he did a lot if you don't know
who william goldman is for christ's sake
uh he did all the president's men
marathon man the princess bride probably
the one he's best known for like in uh
sort of cult movie circles uh butch
cassidy the sundance kid i believe he
won an oscar for that and it also has a
score by the oscar-winning multiple
multiple oscar winning jerry goldsmith
so
what is this movie about like i said
this is
it you can say it's kind of like a
killer doll movie but not really it's
more like a psychological day i guess
they do kind of leave it ambiguous as to
whether
the dummy is actually alive or not i
tend to think probably not but you could
kind of go either way and if you want to
like feel like the dummies like alive
then that's up to you i don't think i
ever read the william goldman novel that
this was based on cause like i said he
adapted his own novel like to the
screenplay and he changed some stuff
around um because you know different
things work in a book that wouldn't
necessarily work in a movie uh so i'm
not entirely sure how the book goes uh
if the doll is actually alive in there
there's also if you guys have seen i
don't know if you guys have seen there's
another kind of killer ventriloquist
dummy um movie back from the 40s i think
it came out in 1945 called dead of night
and this is kind of a little bit more
along those lines and it's interesting
because i would call it a horror film
it's a psychological horror film for
sure um i feel like a lot of the
marketing materials uh called it a
terrifying love story because there's
also kind of like a romance in there as
well so it's kind of one of those 70s
like i said it's just this is really
classy it's just like good movie it's
not even just oh it's a great horror
movie it's just a good movie like in
general it's just like a great [ __ ]
movie and just great acting performances
great writing it's just and it's also
like super super creepy you know it has
that going for it too i remember also
that there was a great trailer for this
like there wasn't even really a trailer
because it was basically just the
ventriloquist dummy his name is fats and
he's just basically on a black
background like staring at the screen
like seeing this really creepy rhyme and
i remember
that ad and i remember a lot of people
that grew up in the 70s like seeing that
ad and being like really really freaked
out by it which like i said it's on
youtube so if you want to go look it's
like magic 1978 trailer or whatever i
think there were two different ones but
they were both like pretty much the same
which is this dummy like talking to the
camera that's like super creepy
but yeah so
what we have is anthony hopkins
is playing um a guy named corki withers
now at the very beginning he's like
a failing magician i guess like he has
this mentor named merlin
and merlin is dying and i love the first
scene of this like the opening scene of
this is so great because
so corky has gone to like this amateur
night and he's doing his magic uh trick
right but he's telling merlin you know
oh i finally got brave enough to get up
on stage and do my magic act and he's
talking he's telling merlin like how
much everybody loved it and how awesome
he was and all this other stuff and then
meanwhile they're showing like what
actually happened and he like completely
took the pipe and it's like nobody was
like even paying attention or they were
just like laughing at him or like
getting up and leaving or whatever so
already you kind of have a disconnect
between
reality and you know and what his
perception of it is or what he's trying
to portray to the world
so after that we kind of cut ahead a
year
now we're at the same club but now
burgess meredith who's playing um kind
of a high-powered like william morris
age like talent agent has apparently
discovered corki and he's bringing
somebody else to this club like to show
him he's got this great [ __ ] act and
he's really going places he wants to
like you know he he wants to make him a
star basically so what has happened in
the year like since we see uh corki
taken the pipe you know with his magic
act is that he has learned to do
ventriloquy i guess is how you say it
and he has added this dummy fats to his
act
so that because he's anthony hopkins in
this movie comes across as like this
really timid
shy
um kind of sorry about the background
noise like my neighbor's doing yard work
again but yeah so anyway so he comes
across as like this really really shy
timid uh you know person
so what he has done
is that he's taking all this stuff about
like his lack of confidence in his magic
act
and he has
added this ventriloquist dummy fats who
is essentially like taking the piss out
of him so it's almost kind of like he's
taking like the criticisms of like the
audience or he's anticipating the
criticisms beyond it's like oh you suck
and all this other kind of stuff and
he's putting in this dummy so he's
making it like a back and forth now and
this has been like a really successful
tactic for him because like you know
just a year has gone by and since he's
added fats to the act uh you know that's
just like kind of like a smart mouth in
him all the time and like tell him how
much he sucks and everything you know
while he's just this shy oh you know
don't say things like that you know what
i mean so it's just kind of like back
and forth so since he's added that he's
gotten like really successful like
there's lines around the [ __ ] block
like to come see him and everything
so like i said um you know burgess
meredith's character uh ben green who he
who fats calls gangrene gangrene so
that's what i'm gonna call them too uh
so gangrene basically is like you know
all these like all the networks are
interested you know they want you to go
you know we want you to play vegas and
then we want you to do all these shows
we want to go to carson maybe you'll get
your own variety show and all this other
kind of stuff so it really seems like
his agent is like pulling for him and he
really wants to go places so at first
corki seems like really jazzed about
this like you know i'm going to be a
star i might be famous and everything
like that
but then
uh a little problem a little tiny
problem arises when gangrene says that
well you know if you're gonna have a
network show like you know for union
rules and everything like that you have
to have a medical exam which doesn't
seem like that big a deal but corki has
a [ __ ] fit about it now the reason
that he has a fit about it which we're
already starting to suspect but i don't
think that gangrene suspects it just yet
although he does suspect it like not too
long after this is that
corky knows that something is
seriously mentally the matter with him
and he doesn't want to um subject
himself to a medical exam and have them
perhaps uh find out what his
psychological state is like because it
seems to be
disintegrating in the sense that he is
um
he's basically becoming
a split personality i guess you want to
say because he basically talks to fats
his ventriloquist dummy as if it's
another person
and
you know so but he seems to know that
there's something the matter with that
and he doesn't want other people to find
out
so because he refuses to take the
medical exam and he just will not he
just will not subject himself to it um
and ben green is just like man come on
it's not a big deal you really have to
do it so corky decides that he's just
going to run away
you know what i mean that's just to get
away from it because he's like if he
feels too much pressure he's in new york
city at the beginning
so what he decides to do to go hide
is that he goes back to uh the catskills
like this little town in the catskills
where he grew up
and he goes back to um see he's kind of
stops by his parents house but it's like
there's nobody there like his family's
dead or whatever so he goes to this um
it's like an old like cabin resort where
his high school crush whose name was
peggy ann snow played by ann margaret uh
where her family used to live so he
decides he's going to go up there
because it's this sort of remote like
cabin whatever
and so he goes up there and he finds out
that peggy is actually still there like
her parents have died and have left her
this resort and it's really kind of like
this down at heel like she's like you
know the catskills are dying no one's
really staying up here anymore so
there's really nobody staying there so
he basically goes up there um and hides
in this cabin and doesn't want anybody
to know that he's there and the excuse
that he's telling himself is that oh you
know i'm just this timid person and i'm
afraid of success and i couldn't handle
the pressure so i just came up here to
hide i mean and peggy knows who he is
she's seen him on tv and stuff like that
and she remembers him from high school
so even though she's married
subsequently she married her high school
sweetheart whose name is duke but he's
away all the time and she seems like
she's not real satisfied in the marriage
she seems like she's kind of like stuck
in a rut she doesn't like hate her
husband but you know she seems like it's
you know the magic is gone i guess if
you want to say that so
a little bit of a romance starts to
develop between uh corki and peg
while the husband is away
now
as this
part of the movie goes on as i said
it gets more and more clear
that corki is losing his [ __ ] marbles
in the sense there's this one really
great scene where
he's talking about his mentor merlin who
we saw at the very beginning of the film
and how
merlin and his wife who was also his
assistant like in his magic act how they
used to do like this mind reading thing
with the cards and it's like he would
always say oh that meant that you were
soul mates if you could like guess each
other's cards because you're like you
know sharing thoughts and you're like
simpatico and stuff
so he wants to do this well actually peg
asks him to do it she's like come on
let's do it it'll be fun and all this
other kind of stuff and he initially
does not want to
and there's this really really tense
scene where they're sitting at the table
and like
she and he's like asking her like
concentrate on the card like to guess
what it is and all this stuff and then
he starts getting like really really
angry and he just like like lashes out
and it's like you know you're not trying
hard enough you're con you're not
concentrating so you know that he's just
like flipping out
now this kind of goes on peg doesn't
really seem to notice um too much
although she is like a little bit afraid
of him because like i said he
there's that whole issue where he kind
of like flies in a rage there but she
kind of starts to fall for him again
like i said they knew each other back in
high school but he had a huge crush on
her back then but he was like and she
knew that he did but he was never really
had the balls to ask her out or anything
like that so he was like you know
admiring her from afar type of thing but
you know he she thinks he's like you
know kind of sweet and everything so
they like i said they kind of start
hooking up
and then um there's kind of a thing too
where fats starts to get and i'm talking
about him like he's a separate character
because that's kind of how corky sees
him as a separate character and fats is
basically like hey you know that woman's
coming between us and it's like you
can't leave me behind and all this other
kind of stuff so you know it's kind of
going that way like i said he's got
arguing with the puppet and [ __ ] like
that
so at some point
duke the husband returns a little
earlier than he was supposed to
and immediately starts to suspect that
some little shenanigans are going on
with uh corki and pig which he is
correct about but obviously they're not
gonna like you know they're trying to
like deny it no we never slept together
what are you talking about if you know
what i mean it's that type of thing even
though they obviously did uh so it gets
very very awkward
now as uh corky's mental state starts to
deteriorate further he's basically in
his cabin and he's arguing with fats
like back and forth and like pretty uh
you know this is very like
big deal like severe argument right and
they're just like screaming at each
other
and it so happens that ben green
gangrene his agent uh has found him
and sees part of this uh display like he
just comes into the cabin and he's just
like
uh what you doing there cork like
fighting with your [ __ ] puppet
and uh corki tries unsuccessfully to
kind of be like um well yeah this is
just like a new act we're doing don't
you you know funny yeah this is like my
new gig and it's like you were right i
was just afraid of success but i'm up
there working on a new bit and it's
going to be so cool
and at this point you know the the agent
has who has suspected that there was
something that mattered with him has
come up here to like essentially prove
it to himself and he's like uh yeah dude
bro i think there's something really
really the matter with you and i really
want to get you some help because i mean
you know his agent is actually a good
guy he does actually want corky to be
successful and he knows that his
psychological state is getting in the
way of that so he's like basically you
know come back with me we'll get you
some psychological help you know we can
still do this
and everything like that and he's like
and then there's another really great
scene too and a lot of people that
review this maybe like talk about this
scene because it's just
that's why i'm saying this is just such
such a great movie because
this scene this which is like two or
three minutes long and it's like almost
all silent but it's like super super
tense because basically what gangrene
says is like okay um
i will stop giving you [ __ ]
if we can sit here in this room for five
minutes and fats doesn't talk right
because that's kind of what what corky
does when he doesn't know what to say
because like i said he's very timid he's
very shy so he just picks up the puppet
and the puppet can just say whatever and
nobody said oh it's the puppet so it's
kind of like his it like channeling his
id or something like that
but you know through the puppet so he
can get away with it
so he's like okay we're just gonna sit
here i'm gonna smoke a cigar and i'm
gonna look at you we're you know we're
gonna sit across from each other and
fats can't talk for five minutes like we
can talk but fats can't talk because
that actually fat's voice that is
anthony hopkins doing that voice um but
you know it's obviously like a different
voice because it's like
but it's like it's the same guy and
honestly i think they did a lot of voice
over but i'm pretty sure uh because i've
heard that there's like you know a bunch
of extra stuff like on the blu-ray and
they sh they have like some kind of
archival footage of anthony hopkins
doing
ventriloquy like he had actually learned
some ventriloquist so he could do some
of it in the movie and like you can kind
of see like in the movie like sometimes
like his throat is moving and stuff like
that so he did actually like learn to do
it all this a lot of it is voice over
so they're sitting there and at first
corki's all like i can make him stop
talking for five years this will be
super easy you know what i mean and then
like as the scene goes on uh how long
has it been now he's like 30 seconds
yeah sure does seem like a long time
because you know he's not gonna be able
to do it he's like starting to sweat and
[ __ ] like that and it's like two and a
half minutes and then he just like looks
at him and it's like it's so sad that's
another thing too it's like he's a
[ __ ] crazy he he knows he's like
there's something that matter with him
and it's just like tragic because he
can't help it and he just like looks at
his age and he's like i can't make it
you know i just can't do it and then he
just like snatches the puppet up and
starts talking in the puppet's voice and
it's just like this sad like really
really tense scene
so after that point things start going
wildly off the rails because since the
since ben
you know gangrene now knows that corki
is
looney tunes um he's basically saying oh
well you know they're gonna come they're
gonna put you up put you away now and
it's gonna ruin your whole entire life
so basically fat says you have to kill
him um so again another like really good
scene but so as it goes on from there
like i said i don't want to spoil like
too much about it but
even though i probably just did but
but yeah so uh so the dummy
does kind of like start killing people
like to get people out of the way um and
there is i guess because i have seen
some reviewers say they thought they
left it ambiguous as to whether the doll
was actually alive or if
corki just thought he was
i'm pretty sure i'm i'm team i don't
think the doll is alive even though
there's a couple scenes in there where
you know it could be argued that and and
like i took i could be totally wrong
about this but i don't think the
intention was for the doll to be alive i
think the intention was for corki to
believe that the doll was alive and that
was it was a separate entity and that it
was doing stuff like against his wishes
i guess but like i said you could read
it as like you know the dummy possessed
him or
you know or something you could read it
like that if you wanted to i'm kind of
team i don't think the doll is alive but
if you want to read it that way it's uh
totally legit but yeah so like i said
this came out in 1978 i don't really
know i could like i said i don't really
know if it did all that well like at the
box office because it seemed like it
sort of disappeared even though it's
like a brilliant movie and like i said
there's like so
i mean there's so many oscar winners
there's like so much talent behind it
it's just like and it's so so creepy and
like i said it's not a straight-up
horror movie and it's you know it's very
much like a psychological
uh kind of thing more than a horror
thing like but like i said if you like
killer dog it's not like chucky or
anything like that that's kind of a
different thing but it has that really
sort of creepy and i even think i i
think i read somewhere that what was
that rl stein that goosebumps that was
about the dummy what the [ __ ] is that
dummy's name i know i've seen some of
the goosebumps movies and i read some of
the books when i was younger but i can't
remember what that i can't remember what
that doll was moved but i don't know but
that but the dummy in the in the
goosebumps book i think is based on fats
because like i said i think a lot of
people saw that trailer back even they
didn't see the movie and they saw the
trailer back then and were like what the
[ __ ] because it is like a pretty creepy
trailer and um
fats the ventriloquist dummy is like a
super super creepy i mean all the trolls
dummies are kind of creepy but um he's
like one of the creepiest ones because
it kind of looks like anthony hopkins
but
not like i don't know like the doll like
the eyes and [ __ ] like that are really
creepy but yeah so if you haven't seen
it
you really should i feel like it's one
of the most underrated horror movies of
the 70s all the acting is great it's
just like the direction is great it's a
beautiful looking movie um and it's just
just great like psychological horror
just kind of ramps up and rants ramps up
you know like i said there's kind of a
romance thing in there and it's almost
kind of like i mean i think honestly in
my opinion this is one of anthony
hopkins best performances particularly
toward the end when he's just like
losing it and he's just like you know
screaming at this dummy and the dummy
screaming back and they're having like
arguments and stuff it's just like so
and it sounds like funny when you put it
like that but it's totally not funny
like in the context of the movie it's
actually kind of horrifying but yeah you
can definitely see
like
where anthony hopkins because you know
it's a lot of people i think maybe after
silence of the lambs came out and was
like such a big um you know hit and
everything i think maybe a lot of people
or me you know maybe a lot of people
kind of went back and revisited this i
don't know i just kind of feel like it
didn't
i feel like it didn't really get the
attention that it deserves and i feel
like it still doesn't like considering
the
caliber of the talent behind it you know
so but i definitely feel like more
people should see it so if you haven't
seen it
i'm not sure where else it's streaming
but it's definitely it was on shutter
but i don't think it's on there anymore
um but it is on 2b for free if you want
to watch it so it might be on amazon
prime as well i'm not really entirely
sure but if you don't have amazon prime
or you don't want to pay to rent it or
whatever uh it is on 2b for free
although it does have ads but you can
see it on there and i definitely
recommend it because especially if you
like creepy doll movies because it's
like one of the creepiest [ __ ] doll
movies ever this one i should eventually
get around to doing dead of night too i
don't usually do
i don't know i was gonna say i don't
usually do movies that old but i guess
it doesn't really matter i can do
whatever [ __ ] movies i want right
right but uh yeah if you like
ventriloquist dummy you know [ __ ] and
killer doll movies and you want to see
like the [ __ ] a super super
high
end
killer doll if you petrolli's dummy doll
movie you definitely need to see magic
so go to 2b watch it and we'll talk
about it down in the comments and that
will do it for this flickers of fear for
this week and i will see you guys on the
next one
bye